given capital f of x is equal to g of x
to the third power where the graph of g
and its tangent line at x equals 4 are
shown what is the value of f prime of 4
so they give us g of x right over here
in blue and they also show us the slo
they show us the tangent line at x
equals 4 right over here so we need to
figure out f prime of 4. so let's just
rewrite this information they've given
us
we know that f of x f of x is equal to
g of x to the third power
so i'll write it like this g of x
g of x
to the third power
so we want to figure out what f prime of
x is when x is equal to 4 so let's just
take the derivative here of both sides
with respect to x
so take the derivative of the left hand
side with respect to x
and take the derivative of the right
hand side
with respect to x
so the left hand side this is just going
to be capital f prime of x
capital f prime of x now on the right
hand side i have a composite i have g of
x to the third power
so first we can view this as the product
of the derivative of g of x to the third
power with respect to g of x so there we
can literally just apply what we know
about the
power rule if the derivative of x to the
third is 3x the derivative of x to the
third with respect to x is 3x squared so
the derivative of g x to the third with
respect to g of x is just going to be 3
times g of x
to the second power and then we're going
to multiply that times the derivative of
g of x with respect to x so times
g prime
of x and this comes straight out of the
chain rule derivative of this the
derivative of g of x to the third with
respect to g of x which is this times
the derivative of g of x with respect to
x which is that right over
right over there
so now let's just substitute we want we
want to figure out what this derivative
is when x is equal to 4.
so we could say
that f
prime
of 4
is equal to
times g of 4
squared times g prime
of 4.
so what is g of 4 what is g of 4 going
to be well we can just look at our
function right over here when x equals 4
our function is equal to
3.
our function is equal to 3. so g of 4 is
equal to 3 and what's g prime of 4
so when our when x equals 4 g prime of 4
is the slope of the tangent line and
they've drawn us they've drawn the
tangent line when x equals 4 here so
what is the slope of this line
so we just have to think about change in
y over change in x and i'll look at that
between two
integer valued coordinates so it looks
like between these two points and when
we increase x
by
2 we decrease y
we decrease y
by 4.
so as you remember slope is rise over
run or change in y over change in x so
the slope of the tangent line here the
slope is equal to our change in y
negative four over our change in x and
this is just this is going to be equal
to
negative two so this is equal to
negative two so this simplifies
to
f prime
of 4 is equal to
i'm just in a new color
3 squared is 9 times 3 is 27
times negative 2
times
negative
which is equal to negative 54. so f
prime of 4 is negative
54.